oui plusieurs époques
jacno il ya eu la première époque et l
époque stinky toys 76 77 et a vécu quand
même au club band reda à londres un des
moments les plus forts c'était le
premier festival pain qu'avec siouxie
les sexpistols et les stinky toys
ça s'est passé comment ces couacs en âge
que tu gardes cette foule à l'image moi
je peux très bien préciser c'est que
c'est vraiment des ragots de dire que
c'est une période forte parce qu'il y
avait surtout une bande de petits cons
notamment des crétins du type sid
vicious à dire à tous ces petits gars là
qui était vraiment dès que des couillons
qui faisait attention à leurs managers
qui rêvait déjà de show-business est
pognon réduire les vacances étaient
déboutées là tu es en train de détruire
la légende des packs après ça n'a jamais
existé
après il ya eu un coût énorme ça a été
le lit lovers qui est devenu amoureux
solitaires pour lier ou cinq morceaux
que vous aviez fait avec kelly tous les
deux au départ wake on avait fait avec
les stinky toys ce qui va ce que c'était
un peu méconnaissable quand on a refait
sur la trame
un morceau après tu es devenu producteur
compositeur arrangeur tafer
mathématiques modernes et surtout tu as
fait le premier 33 de dao
oui ouais ouais mythomane oui je voulais
pas écouté sa cassette
avant quand hitler n'est la première
fois tu voulais pas non ça veut parce
que je sais pas j'avais la tête ailleurs
machin et c'est lui qui m'a poussé à
l'écouté je l'écouté et je trouve ça
super parce qu'il y avait une chanson
qui ressemblait fin dans ma tête
un truc de john key rien que pour ça je
te veux c'est bien pauline par contre
n'oublie pas sa peau était un tube
énorme tu pense qu'elle est et ce
qu'elle aurait pu avoir une carrière de
chanteuse ou qualité plus fait pour le
cinéma finalement je pense que l'été
fait pour tous parce que j'étais doué
pour pour tous est une question de deux
talents simplement elle n'a pas voulu
promotionner du tout
y a pas tord ou à raison chacun
décide ce qu'il veut tu as vécu comment
cet été d'enfer
ok
difficilement
[Applaudissements]
mais je travaillais avec eux avec
jacques higelin ouais bah oui t'as
produits tombés du ciel
oui
je me suis concentré
ouais alors maintenant tout sortant dont
ce que tu appelles ton premier vrai
album c'est à dire t'es loin t'es près
c'est très étonnant de ta part parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya comme ça c'est ni
rosbif nîmes et istres on pourrait dire
que c'est vraiment français il ya une
reprise de chevalier d'ailleurs dans le
halal bonne il ya une chanson dont
françoise hardy a fait les paroles way
to me fout en rogne qui est très bien
oui et pyatt a bossé avec bourgoin le
mec de chagrin d'amour avec un
merveilleux z'oiseaux ya des bonnes
idées
cela dit dit long
c'est les deux seules interventions
extérieures way pour en soi mais que je
trouve très brillante et et qui me
corresponde sinon je les aurais pas fait
évident tant entendu parler du blind
test de lunettes noires c'est de
l'anglais dont celle anglais ça veut
dire qu'on va te passer des disques que
tu vois pas et tu vas les reconnaître
[Applaudissements]
la premier regard des maracas licenciés
je m'en fous mais ce soir c'est le mec
qui chantaient dansaient mars hauteur et
tout ça comment il s'appelle ouais c'est
sur twitter
complet
[Musique]
ça ça vient de ressortir vient de
ressortir le 45 tours c'est à 10 ans
talhouët
je sais ce pc ouais ça s'est marié les
gars renvoi
quand même dire que ça a été produit par
john key la whey ce qui m'avait rendu
très jaloux ce moment là parce qu'on
voulait toujours être produit mais la
maison de disques voulait pas parce que
j'en ai trop cher c'est un des premiers
disques comme ça retour au simplissime
mais ça c'était une bonne chance mais on
sortait de l'hyper production c'était
les premiers morceaux qui était très
simple comme ça et ça c'était une de
bonnes chances mais parce que c'est
après ils ont fait du disco absolue
c'est vraiment froid dans le dos mais ça
oui ça dure une heure à pau où elle a
trouvé très très long mais je sais c'est
les couillons new york est là où ils ont
des 52 ouais ouais
inspiré des choucroutes pas mal non mais
super patois numéro trois clubs ce tracé
un peu james bond
ouais là tu en connais qui suit la
tendance et ouais
ça c'est génial ça s'est fait en
belgique c'était fermé ça s'entend
ness
c'est marc moulin en cours
quoi
warsage c'est parce que cela les tomates
tu sais pas ce qu'on voyait les terran
lui il eut bien moi je sais pas ce que
ça mais c'est un bordel disco à ben non
c'est vachement bien
j'te jure un boum c'était l'ex bras se
souvient pas de calais si c'était des
belges ouais
moscow disco oui il y avait tout est à
saint tropez est en travaux ah oui mais
dick rivers le chanter mieux sont jeudi
c'est de la merde pourquoi c'est de la
merde
je la quittais mon briquet la improbable
super nanny
dans l'est
sa noire ça va lui faire plaisir
il ya près de versailles dans le coup tu
connais fred merci tu vois pas ce que
c'est
non je vois pas on a eu à -1 à -1
à moins que ça soit le zoulou la croûte
chez ou way
ses courtiers séquelles justicier rêver
mais moi je connais pas trop là ce genre
de trucs mais je vois très bien
tu vois le genre je vois les gens
changer
[Musique]
c'est james key manager quand même
don quichotte
ça serait pas la petite soeur de lio à
ces genres ces genres sais plus j'ai
raison sinon vient pas portugaise mais
enfin tu verra son nom elle et du sud
[Musique]
c'est par jil caplan
non c'est pas jil caplan ces gens
viva chile poule c'est pas les beatles
tu vois pas qui c'est non je donne ma
langue au ras ouais on lui
c'est à nice et elvin a très bien tu
vois un peu cher pierre et gilles enfin
tu vois pas très à l'aise king
c'est beau séjour sera très vieux une
façon de lui écrit des super musique
canadiens rien à dire voir le suivant
[Musique]
m
alexis
merci
zuma qui s'est aggravée ouais je pense
que c'est taxi girl c'est ça le titre
c'est quoi
sont pas fait chier remarquer les
chercheurs mais normalement ouais non
sauver la jeune artiste a réussi après
le titre et si ça y est c'est encore
routier
le piège de trois fois quatre fois c'est
qu'est ce qu'il a de plus que moi ce
n'est grand écran la wii alors que bon
alors carrière on l'applaudît
non
je sais pas
ah bon pour les tomates
[Musique]
premier vrai album de l'amoureuse
solitaire jacno t'es loin t'es près
premier single tu es grands yeux bleus
pour qui tu sais je t'embrasse et qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est moi
ah oui
aussi
tu fais comme cost riches
taux
[Musique]
les cheveux
sommes nous
et m
oh
tanger tétouan
je
j'étais dans une
le bhoutan
forest
m
ton bien
le temps
m
je
bientôt la vie
m
hamon
biblique et bien plus
à manger
je
soit 12 mars
se couche qui veut
hewson
et pourtant
le chef
combien de
[Musique]
si souvent
bien trop bas
les riches pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu